What if I told you that the problem with
your writing is not that you're a bad writer,
but that you know too much? I ran a university
writing lab for seven years, and these days I
work with nonfiction writers of all stripes. But
the problem is the same. The patterns that experts
use to think about their subject fight with the
patterns that readers use to understand it. And
that fight has a name. It's called interference,
and it's the number one problem of expert writing.
So in this video, I'm going to show
you why experts write the worst,
how to spot interference
patterns in your own writing,
and how to fix them so that your ideas are
as clear to your readers as they are to you.
So, what is interference, and why
does it happen? Well, quite simply,
interference is the mismatch between the
patterns that you use when you're generating
the text and the patterns that readers use
whenever they're interpreting the text.
See, that's the thing. If you're writing valuably,
then the kind of thinking that you're doing is way
too complex to sort out in your head. It's a
little bit like Christmas lights. So you can
imagine having a set of Christmas lights that you
pull out once a year and hang up around the house.
And you know how it is — they're always a
tangled mess. And before you can actually
put them on display, you need to go through
this toilsome process of untangling everything.
And that's really what the first phase of writing
is. Whenever you're writing, it's not like an
essay shape, or whatever genre you're using. It's
not in that shape in your head. It's a total mess.
And you can't just go for a walk and sort
that mess out. It doesn't happen that way.
You need to, in the first place, use the writing
as an extension of your thinking. And if you do
expert writing, then you know exactly what
I'm talking about — when you're sitting at
the keyboard and you're kind of struggling
to figure out what it even is that you think,
before you can even think about putting
it into an essay shape for a reader.
And so one way to diagram that would be to say
that you're generating. So here's the text that
you and your reader are both going to use, and
you're generating it on this horizontal axis
of time, where you're simultaneously thinking
about the world and writing about the world.
And so the text is being generated according
to these patterns where you as an expert
are thinking about the world. But the
problem with that is that readers are
using the text on a completely different axis.
They want to use the text to understand the world.
So if you think about that expert writing process,
you're kind of moving through the text in time.
Think about it this way. You as the writer
start at the top of the text with a question
or a problem, something that you don't know,
because you're generating new ideas. And so you
start at the top of the text not knowing, and you
kind of keep on chipping away at this draft until
you get to the bottom of the text where you're
like, "Aha, I've got it now. It's complete."
But look at the pattern that you've
just generated. You've moved from
a state of not knowing, a state of uncertainty,
to a state of certainty or knowing. And so
now if you just hand this off to your reader,
they need to follow your entire intellectual
journey from not knowing to knowing.
Now, that's just one example of a writer
pattern that doesn't serve readers. You're
not making a mistake. Everybody goes through
this. But the thing to just recognize is that
as you're generating this
text, you are simultaneously
thinking about the world with your own
expert patterns. We're going to talk about
those in a second. But those patterns make
it difficult for the reader to use your text.
And it's not to just say that the patterns
that writers use and readers use are different.
It's to say that the patterns that
writers use, especially experts,
which they use to generate the
text, interfere with the patterns,
the expectations, that readers use to process
the text. Readers do not want to move from
uncertainty to certainty. For example,
they want the certainty right up front.
And if you want an easy guide to the patterns
that readers use to process your text,
then you can grab my visual guide to expert
writing down below the like button. It's four
pages as a PDF, and it just gives you a
kind of road map to looking at your essay
and thinking about it the way that readers
will. These aren't like my rules to writing.
These are just the kind of expectations
that readers bring to nonfiction writing.
It's all based on reader psychology. And so
if you can think about your text this way,
then it becomes really easy to move from that
first phase of writing, where you as the writer
are generating the text while thinking about
it, transferring that over to the reader draft.
But how can you spot interference in your own
writing? Well, you might think that one way
that you could find it would be to give your text
to readers and see what they give you back. But
honestly, I think readers are the worst people
to talk to for feedback about your draft.
The reason that you don't ask readers for
feedback about your draft is for the same
reason that you don't ask a fish how to
catch a fish, or you don't ask a woman
for dating advice if you're a man. Ladies,
do not pillory me in the comments for this,
but let me tell you that the worst dating advice
I've ever received has always come from women.
Why is that? Well, I don't know for
sure, but what I do know for sure is that
what you say you want and what you
actually want are two different things.
I had a girl one time tell me that she wanted
a guy just like in the movie About Time. Have
you ever seen this movie? So I heard this,
and I watched this movie, and here's the
movie. It's about this dork who just can't
figure it out with women, but in the movie,
he's got a time machine. And so every time he
fumbles the football, he can just hit undo and
go back in time and try it again. And the entire
movie is him just fumbling, fumbling, fumbling.
And girls watch that and they melt and they
say, "Oh, see, that's what I want." Well, guys,
go out there and try it. Watch that movie. Use it
like a playbook and see how that works for you.
And honestly, it works the same way with
readers. They'll tell you one thing,
but what they actually want is another thing.
So when your text doesn't work with readers,
here's what they'll tell you. They'll
say, "It's unclear." They'll say, "Oh,
it's disorganized. It's a little fuzzy.
It's dense." Remember back in university
when your professor would leave you a comment
in the margins that says "unclear, fix this"?
The problem here is that readers don't have
the vocabulary to describe what's happening.
So honestly, if you receive a comment like
"dense" or "unclear" or "disorganized,"
that advice is really worth nothing. It
doesn't tell you what to do. It just tells you
the way that the reader is experiencing the
text. Readers don't have this language of saying,
like, "Your writing patterns
interfere with my reading patterns."
And just understand that these words — dense,
unclear, disorganized, and those other kind
of general terms that you get in feedback about
your writing — those describe the symptom of your
writing, but they don't describe the cause. What
they're describing, in other words, is friction.
Readers want to move through your text. They want
to process it according to their reading patterns,
but those patterns are interfering with
the patterns that you've left on the page.
One example that I've already provided is your
own intellectual journey from uncertainty to
certainty. That's a pattern that's going
to interfere with the reader patterns.
Readers don't want to move from uncertainty to
certainty. They want to move from stability to
instability. And that's a different video, but
it's just one of the reader kind of preferred
motions or journeys through a text. They
want to begin in a familiar world and
then discover that there's something wrong with
that world that they need to understand better.
That's one of the reader kind of expectations
whenever they come to a piece of nonfiction.
So readers, a lot like women in the dating market,
don't have the best language for describing
what it is they want. So if you get negative
feedback from them, take it all with a grain
of salt and try to get to the bottom of
what it is that readers actually want.
And this concept of interference
is really important for writers
to understand, because when you get
that negative feedback from readers,
you don't want to wind up having
to work on the wrong thing.
I'm actually working with a writer right now who's
writing a pillar essay for a coaching program
that he's about to launch. And so the essay is
kind of meant to introduce potential customers
and the internet at large to a concept that he's
kind of owning in his personal brand. And again,
he's building a coaching educational offer
on the other end of it. But so what he's
done now — this is a very kind of niche topic,
and I've been working with him on this draft.
Now, he, like many writers whenever they come
to me, thought that the problem would just be
a matter of line editing. So he would bring me
his draft and I would apply some patterns to it
and turn it into a draft that works.
But it doesn't really work that way.
Like, I really think it's important to
think about the writer's draft and the
reader draft as two separate documents. You
have one draft where you as the expert are
thinking about the world. You're thinking
about your ideas as you're generating the text,
but then that text is going to mirror your
own patterns of thinking, which involve a lot
of confusion and kind of recursive looping in on
itself, and fixing this, and getting pulled down
that side trail, and trying this out. There's a
lot of experimentation and kind of iteration over,
you know, however long it takes you to generate
the text — many days at least — that goes into it.
And so you can't really fix that at the level
of line editing. I really think it's important,
like, once you as the writer are
satisfied, to walk away from that
text. And that's really hard to do, because
you've invested so much of yourself into it.
Working with this writer's draft, it's
a little bit like giving directions
to a restaurant to a friend. So
imagine you're at a restaurant,
your friend's going to come meet you. You've
driven to the restaurant from your house,
and now your friend calls you and
they're asking for directions, right?
So what are you going to do? Are you going
to tell your friend the steps that you took
to arrive at the restaurant? That's not very
helpful to your friend, right? Your friend is
expecting you to start your directions where
you understand they are, and to give them the
appropriate level of context to let them know how
to get to the place where you've arrived, right?
You use the text just like — you know, you
arrived at the restaurant following your own path,
and that path served you well. Nothing
wrong with the path that you've taken.
It's the steps that you needed to take in
order to arrive at this place of clarity.
But now you need to show the reader how to get
there. And you're an expert. The reader is not
starting their journey to the restaurant from
your home. You're starting from a completely
different walk of life. You have all these
other experiences, background knowledge,
and just patterns of thinking that do
not suit the reader patterns of thinking.
And so in most cases, whenever an expert brings
me a text that they're preparing for a specific
kind of reader, I think it's really hard for
them emotionally to accept that they need to
write a new draft. But honestly, that draft isn't
really so hard to write once you've done all your
thinking. Like, once you've arrived at a place
where you think, "Okay, I have all the pieces
that I need," then it's actually a lot easier to
map out a trail for the reader to get there. And
the visual guide to expert writing is basically a
collection of all the patterns that I use whenever
I'm thinking about how to prepare a reader to go
from where they are to where you want them to be.
Why is it that the more that you know about
a topic, the worse a writer you become? Well,
on the one hand, of course, you're the one
person in the world who should be writing
about your topic, because you're an expert on it.
But on the other hand, because you're an expert,
you have compressed a lot of your knowledge into
really tight kind of conceptual packets and
heuristics that become shorthands for you,
but become very dense and difficult to manage
for people who don't know what you know.
And this is sometimes popularly known as the curse
of knowledge. But I don't want to use that phrase,
because honestly, for those of us who are in
the space of writing, that itself becomes one
of these condensed packets of information, and
I think it's not exactly what I'm trying to say.
The popular associations that we have with the
curse of knowledge — in case you're not familiar,
this is a concept that comes from C.S.
Lewis, and it basically just means that
you as a writer forget what it's like
to not know what you already know.
And so the advice that follows from this insight
about the curse of knowledge is to write simply,
or write at a fifth-grade level. And that's
not the takeaway that I want to make,
which is why I don't really want to use
that concept, the curse of knowledge.
Instead, I want to look at this issue to really
think about what happens when you're an expert.
So whatever the field is that
you're writing in, whatever it is,
your domain of expertise — the fact that you have
expertise in that domain means that you have gone
through a lot of learning and condensing of
information. Like, when you learn something,
you only need to learn it one time, and
then that becomes a kind of landmark,
or a post in the road for you, from where
you can begin the next time you're learning.
In other words, you start thinking about your
concept using these compressed kind of chunks
of information that become like the
private machinery of your discipline.
You know these concepts really well. You
take them for granted. And there are other
people who are in your space, colleagues
— especially if you're an academic. Now,
it's true of all disciplines, but it's just
easy to think about this among academics.
You know, I worked with a lot of academics for
seven years at the writing center, and what I
found is that these people are generally writing
for each other. And so there are all these kind of
concepts and disciplinary norms that we take for
granted whenever we're writing to those people.
But now, whenever you're tasked with the
problem of making your research valuable to
people who are not inside your discourse community
— which might be the lay public if you're trying
to write a popular book, but it could also be
committees who are issuing grants or funding, or,
you know, private investors, that kind of thing
— you need to make the value of your research
salient to them. And you forget what it's
like to not know everything that you know.
So in one sense it means that yes,
there's a lot that you take for granted,
and so therefore you should present these items
simply. But it's more to say that as an expert,
you don't even realize the amount of compression
and the kind of weird thinking patterns that you
use within your discipline. And they're ones
that you take for granted among your peers. But
whenever you're writing for people who are
outside of that disciplinary community,
it's important to think about what patterns
are they going to be using to interpret this,
because those are the patterns that you need to
use whenever you're trying to reach those readers.
And so the fix here is the advice that
unfortunately you really don't want to hear,
but it's the truth — which is that you can't
think of writing as being a single act.
If you're an expert, if you are writing valuably,
if you are generating new knowledge, you're not
just regurgitating other people's ideas. You're
not doing summaries of other people's ideas,
but you're actually trying to communicate
something valuable, which means you're solving
current problems, right? If you are solving open
problems, if you're answering open questions,
it means you are using your writing as an
extension of your thinking. And so by definition,
as an expert, you are going to be generating your
text along this axis where you are simultaneously
thinking about the world and solving these
problems while you are generating that text.
And so therefore you must get used to the idea
that there's no fixing that draft. There's no
amount of line edits — put a comma here, put these
two things into the same paragraph. It doesn't
work. We can't fix these issues at the surface
level, at the formal level. It's a fundamental
issue of the way that this text was generated.
It was generated to serve your own thinking.
But if you're trying to reach readers, if
you're trying to mobilize your expertise
into something that readers will find
valuable, then we need to generate
a second text. I should almost draw a second
one over here. Here's the one for the reader.
For the reader — and they're going
to use this to understand the world,
right? This one is full of interference. They
can't use it. It was generated for you. And so
after we're done this one, we need to create
a second one for the reader that they can use.
But here's one kind of concrete tip that you
can use whenever you are trying to fix these
problems of interference. So, of course, grab
that PDF. But then one thing you'll notice in it
is that I'm always referring to this fractal
pattern called the index and the discussion.
And so that's kind of a general shape of
idea development. The index is where you
put a kind of high-level concept, and
the discussion is where you pay that
off. And I call it a fractal pattern
because it's a pattern that recurs
at every level of resolution throughout the
text. So we see that index and discussion pattern
at the level of the entire text, where you have
your introduction and then the body. But then
when you zoom into the parts of the body, you
see that there's the index and discussion here.
And the tip is to do what's called the skim test.
And so once you've kind of laid out your ideas
into this index-discussion pattern, what you
can do is highlight just the index positions
and see whether those create a kind
of storyboard for the major steps or
rhetorical moves that you want the reader to move
through. Because the index is supposed to preview
the major piece of information in the entire unit
of discourse. And so the way that you can test
that, as a kind of diagnostic, is to see whether
just the index positions tell a coherent story.
And so that skim test amounts to what's
known as a reverse outline. Right?
Like, of course, a common piece
of advice is to create an outline
for your text. But the problem with that is
that if you create the outline first, then
it's hard to fit especially expert patterns. Like,
as an expert, you're not just writing listicles,
right? You're not writing top five things. And
so it's hard to generate an outline first and
then fill it in, because again, you're using
writing as an extension of your thinking.
So one idea comes, and then you kind of expand
it and start exploring it, and then that might
take you down a little, you know, a little
tributary, and you go down that path, and
right — so it doesn't really work so well if
you're trying to generate an outline first.
So what I recommend instead is: use your
writing in whatever patterns it occurs to
you spontaneously. Like, let your mind wander
while you're writing. Absolutely do not think
about reading patterns while you're generating
your text. But then as you start to adapt the
weird thing that you've developed that served
your own thinking — when you start adapting
that for readers, you do need to make sure that
there's a kind of coherent structure to it all.
And so the way that you can do that
is with this reverse outline, right?
You can look at your text and then draw
lines demarcating the different sections.
And then within those sections, draw a line
that demarcates what's known as the index.
And then look only at those indexes and
see whether they tell a coherent story.
And if, as you're generating this reverse
outline, you cannot really label a part,
well, it's probably still a tangled knot of
Christmas lights, or it's just fluff, right?
Ideally, these indexes throughout the
piece are going to mark the major turns
in your reader's journey. If you go
back to the metaphor about the reader
finding their way to the restaurant,
right? These index positions should be
like the major turns that they're going
to take on the way to the destination.
But you can't really map out the reader
route if you don't know what patterns
they'll use to get there. So be
sure to watch this video next,
because it's going to show you the five reading
patterns that, if you follow them, is going to
make your writing so much better from the reader
perspective. So be sure to go check it out.